fue una carrera contra el tiempo para
evacuar al mayor número de personas
posible cuando francia terminó sus
vuelos sacando un total de 3000 personas
de afganistán pero admitió sin embargo
que no podía llevar su misión hasta el
final para poner a todos a salvo en una
declaración los ministros del exterior y
del ejército franceses dijeron con la
confirmación de que las fuerzas de
estadounidenses encargadas de la
seguridad del aeropuerto de kabul se
retiran en breve el aeropuerto ya no
será lo suficientemente seguro y
nuestras operaciones han terminado por
tanto el viernes
inicialmente francia y otros aliados de
eeuu querían seguir evacuando a sus
nacionales y a los afganos que han
servido a la coalición o cuyas acciones
los han puesto en riesgo con la llegada
de los islamistas al poder presionando
para extender la presencia de eeuu por
unos días para hacer lo posible pero los
talibanes se negaron a cambiar el plazo
y la casa blanca dijo que mantendrá sus
tropas hasta la fecha original de
retirada al 31 de agosto en los últimos
días la seguridad se ha degradado
alrededor del aeropuerto con el ataque
yihadista del jueves y las alertas sobre
otras amenazas inminentes alemania
terminó sus operaciones
y evacuando a más de 5 mil personas
[Música]
hoy no es un día para celebrar la
dramática situación en afganistán
en menos de dos semanas estados unidos y
otras naciones han evacuado a través del
aeropuerto a unas 110.000 personas reino
unido a está a punto de culminar su
misión después de sacar a más de 14.000
están listos para traer a casa sus
tropas y equipos